schulen rücken jetzt wieder in den
mittelpunkt und vor allem die kinder und
deswegen möchte ich nun sprechen mit
doktor martin karsten erst kinderarzt
wir nun zugeschaltet und morgen dr
kasten
sagen sie mir die politik schaut jetzt
also wieder auf die kleinsten aber wie
corona gefährdet sind kinder denn nun
tatsächlich da müssen wir haben sehr das
alter unterscheiden also gerade die
kleinen kinder sind eben nicht so
gefährdet also wir haben so gut wie
nicht gesehen in den letzten acht
monaten dass sich kinder so bis 68 jahre
untereinander angesteckt haben
zu einem echten ausbruch in einer kita
ist es nicht gekommen
natürlich man sieht immer vereinzelt
dass ein kind eine krone infektion hat
aber das ist dann immer wieder das ist
denn immer wieder von außen reingetragen
so ist bin ich ja lang verschwundene bei
ihnen
ich weiß gar nicht warum wir hoffen das
bild kommt gleich wieder weg hör' sie
trotzdem noch
ja genau die kleinsten die kinder sind
also in vor allem im jungen alter nicht
so gefährdet sind sie denn dann trotzdem
diejenigen die dem virus übertragen oder
wie kann man überhaupt erklären dass
jetzt so ein wert darauf gelegt wird
dass die kinder nicht mehr in größeren
gruppen zusammen sind beziehungsweise
wirklich nur noch einen einzigen freund
treffen dürfen
da muss man dazu sagen da gibt es
eigentlich keinen richtigen grund dafür
dass es dazu kommen denn gerade die wir
wissen ja dass sich kind zu kind bei
kleinen kindern sehr sehr geringer
wahrscheinlichkeit nur ansteckt anders
ist es natürlich beim größeren also ich
glaube der focus müsste eben auf die
oberschüler gegeben
wir wissen ja gerade in letzter zeit
dass gerade die 15 bis 25 jährigen also
das sind ja die oberschüler da ist die
eine riesen ansteckungsgefahr und da
müssen wir aufpassen
aber gerade bei den kleinen kindern da
kann also in meinen augen eindeutig
entlassungen gegeben werden denn kleine
kinder sind es nicht und für kleine
kinder kindergartenkinder und die ersten
schuljahre sind sozialkontakte extrem
wichtig und gerade auch alleinerziehende
eltern ist ja auch gar nicht zu
publizieren
und wir haben wirklich in den letzten
monaten gesehen kinder sind bis zehn
jahren nicht vorantreibe
pandemie also ich glaube da können die
eltern entlassungen gegeben aber bei den
älteren kinder bei den oberstufen da
muss darauf geachtet werden und das sind
ja natürlich die partys gemacht werden
aber ich glaube da muss man auch die
eltern und kinder müssen aufgeklärt
werden die oberschule müssen die
verantwortung genommen werden und da
muss dann geguckt werden inwieweit auch
100 unterricht möglich ist und ich sag
immer wieder bei älteren kindern können
klassen getrennt werden also die klasse
sollten halbiert werden die schüler
können auf die online unterricht machen
die kinder jugendlichen sind ja so gut
digitalisiert wo das möglich ist also
ganz klar unterschreiben nachdem alkan
bei großen darauf achten bei oberstufen
das sind die vor antreiber der pandemie
und bei den kleinen kindern wo er eine
anstellung untereinander kind zu kind
extrem unwahrscheinlich ist das ist ein
kleines restrisiko die wir reden müssen
aber wie gesagt kindergartenkinder sind
nicht vor antreiber der pandemie
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren